your talk show was over yeah was that a
time where you were were you depress
then or now no actually not then I was
very elated by bina and I was fine for a
couple of years I this was about
eighteen months ago I I kind of liked my
attendance to my mental well-being what
you describe and I'm just just W I knew
I had to do I just wouldn't do it
yeah some kind of bloody mindedness
within me bless you it's the thing yeah
oh is it is it that warble have the
things I've brought the potent disease
yeah sorry so so it was that it was just
a lack of attentiveness to to the type
of person that I am and the maintenance
that I need to wow conducting myself it
was bad yeah it was bad really bad I
thought I'm gonna get drunk yeah and
then what happened the the during all
that time period I had to get a piece of
pretty major dental surgery yeah but it
was a root canal and and I had to when I
got it it was a painful thing yeah and
after it the doctor said I'm gonna give
you some painkillers and I was like hey
can do am I lost my right to use those
things and he said well this is gonna
hurt a lot I said well I'm not doing him
and he said but look let me just give
you the prescription just in case you
change your mind yeah
when this wears off and I changed my
mind because it was unbelievable so I
call up my for one of a bit my sponsor
yeah and I'm talking to him and there's
like you know helicopters dr. Phil above
my house and all that kind of stuff and
I take this painkiller right and with
dr. Phil lives in the neighborhood - no
no and then I I wouldn't actually I
wouldn't listen to him anyway yeah he's
not really a doctor you know yeah yeah
and then what he he did just I know
you're in the middle of a thing but um I
just have to say something about him
yeah he did an interview with Shelley
Duvall when she was like mentally like
not there mmm and it really just turned
me off to that [ __ ] bastard I'm not a
fan yeah
I'm turned off to that bastard you know
it's funny I had him as a guest on the
late-night show early on and he was
talking to me and but halfway through
then every I thought you have no [ __ ]
idea what I'm talking about
I was talking to him about addiction and
I thought you were thinking yeah yeah
yeah no it doesn't mean he's doesn't
know about others he's a fraud
well as far when it comes to the
understanding what an addictive
personality yes yeah yes yeah more than
that he's just really exploitative
exploitive yeah
[Music]